More than 130 pyramids have been discovered in Egypt,...
...but the Pyramids of Giza are the most famous of all,...
...attracting millions of visitors each year.
Located on the outskirts of Cairo, the archaeological site is called the Giza Necropolis.
The complex is made up of three pyramids,...
...and sitting to the east is the guardian of them all: the Sphinx.
Lying in Pharaoh Khafre's necropolis,...
...the Sphinx is carved from a single block of stone...
...and depicts the pharaoh as a human-headed lion.
The pyramids are over 4,000 years old.
It's estimated between 20 to 30,000 workers were needed...
...to polish and shift the massive limestone blocks into place.
They not only house the remains of the deceased pharaohs,...
...but were also used as storage for the items they would need in the afterlife.
Due to the perfect geometry and sheer structural size,...
...many have argued that the pyramids could not have been built by humans.
Some have claimed, they were variously constructed by angels, the devil,...
...or even visitors from another planet.